we introduced the idea of equations do
you remember that we introduced them we
gave them a definition we also talked
about the difference between equations
and do you remember what they're very
very similar cousins were yeah
expressions well done so we talked about
how to fact they're very similar to each
other they both contain numbers and
algebra but they're not the same
they don't say what's the key thing that
you're missing yeah good sir equal sign
means equation no equal sign must be an
expression okay
now along with that equal sign you got a
whole bunch of different things
okay for instance with an expression you
know if you had some prettier than a b c
XY whatever right you can put any values
in there you like and we spent a whole
exercise on that saying look what if the
purdue rule k/t you whatever what if it
was equal to 1 or 5 or negative 3 you
could put anything in you're like ah
but you can't put anything you like it
to an equation right you know they put
Sen base what did we call those eyes had
a special name son of an S yep
yes solution that's right so when you've
got an equation
not just any values work only certain
values and we call those value solutions
now the process of finding a solution is
what we call solving an equation and
that's what we started looking at
yesterday okay now we're gonna keep on
pushing with that idea solving equations
is a big deal um today we're gonna look
at one of the most simple clients of
equations mainly one-step equations and
it is about five or ten minutes I'm
gonna ask you why do you think they're
called one-step equations but this
little subheading is solving okay now
let's have a look at yes it is page 194
okay and I'm gonna open it up let's have
a look at what a together it starts like
this okay
lots of times people ask me Oh should we
write the question in the past I've
sometimes said yes enough sometimes said
no depending what the question was it
equations you should always write down
the question first okay and hopefully as
we went through it you'll see why now
there are two different ways to approach
this they look very very similar to each
other but sort of the nuts and bolts of
how they work underneath very subtly
difference that's what I show you both
question okay so you're good at your
getting right to the answer I'll show us
how we get there okay so how do we get
how do we get the answer right two
methods I don't want to know what the
answer is yet remember I've told you
before how important it is not just to
get you know ants on down the bottom but
to understand well but why is that the
answer how did you get back can you
prove it right so here we go here's my
first method and it's it's alluding back
to what we looked at before do you
remember the analogy I gave you for an
equation was I brought one in do you
remember it was a set of scales and I
hope most of you took a picture of it
son so scales are meant to balance it
scales a bit to balance so this first
way
or solving this equation getting fear
size is balancing so in order to make
this balance I want to do something to
both sides of my set of scales both
sides of my equation that will get
towards W by itself okay now you can see
what can I do to both sides that
balances out but gets the W by itself
yeah good good I'm even gonna do it in
another color and I encourage you to do
so as well if you've got one what I'm
doing to both sides is and subtract
eight there okay so the key idea is I've
done the same thing to both sides I've
balanced now of course we all know eight
minus eight a number Myers itself is
just 0 so you get W here and then 15-8
noise oh yes because you told me that
you're ready okay well done great so
there you go there is the solution and
this is how we do it
by balancing is another way yep so that
will that will still get you to this
right ear top right but it's very
difficult yeah if it gets harder it's
back time and and secondly like how
would you word that like in your book
you're like I can't sit low this is like
would you write out a whole paragraph I
think this would be a lot more concise
my luck we go yeah all right now the
other alternative is what the textbook
calls it cause it backtracking I'm not a
huge fan of that of name but then again
I can't think of a better one myself but
I will tell you what it is to do with
okay think back to when we were doing
order of operations remember those we
looked at for operations
what were they in order do you remember
we started with yet dupes edition and
then subtraction and then yeah you could
do I suppose you could either do
division or multiplication there you go
there's our form okay now do you
remember that along with each operation
okay I might put them in rows along with
each operation we had its opposite
operations right but we gave it a
special name we called it a boom
we called it its inverse do you remember
this is this ringing a bell yes good
excellent do so out of each of these
operations right something will undo the
other ones okay so for instance I should
stay with red the operation that's the
inverse of addition is which means that
the inverse of subtraction okay so what
we've got here right okay backtracking
backtracking is about looking at an
operation that happened here and
thinking about its inverse okay so
really it's about inverses but I think
they're like it sounds cool when they
both start with B it's alliteration
balancing your veteran but this is I
think it's a more accurate way okay so
here's what I'll do I see that the
operation over here is plus a plus a
right so if the operation is plus a then
it's inverse should be minus 8 right
that's what that's what undoes that
operation okay so here what I'll do is
if I undo this I'll have to do it to
this as well if I apply the inverse
minus a to this site I'll do it to that
one so the difference in what I write is
not very much
look almost exactly the same if I do the
inverse or go back to W I apply to
universe their state meditate which is
still 7 because it's still the same
equation now as I emphasized before
there are very very minor differences
between these but part of the reason why
there are very minor differences is
because you only know about 4 operations
right now I left up exponentiation but
we'll get to that later
and as this list of operations grows
you'll I don't know by the end of year
12 if you keep doing maths by that point
you might know say 15 or 20 different
operations more than just these four and
then understand the inverses becomes
much more important so these guys which
look the same right now it's kind of
like I suppose it's a bit like twins you
know when they're born it's like I
seriously can't tell them apart but as
they get older they start to diverge and
they start to look different they get
different haircuts we're men right with
different hands and so on so stay with
them they might look the same right now
but never tell twins they're the same
they'll get very angry of you okay